[Music]
this is geoff hinton because of a back
condition he hasn't been able to sit
down for more than 12 years I hate
standing as much all the time but if I
said I never did succumbs I'm sorry well
at least no standing desks are
fashionable and yeah but I was the head
I was standing when they were since you
can't sit in the car or on a bus
Hinton walks everywhere the walks is a
lot about Hinton and is resolved for
nearly 40 years
Hinton has been trying to get computers
to learn like people do a quest almost
everyone thought was crazy or at least
hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field Google thinks
this is the future the company I was in
thinks the edition company Apple thinks
is future Humpty my own department
thinks it's just probably nonsense and
we shouldn't be doing any more of it so
I took everybody into it except my own
department
[Music]
you obviously grew up in the the UK and
you had this very prestigious family
full of famous mathematicians and
economists and I was curious what it was
like for you yeah there was a lot of
pressure I think by the time I was about
seven I realized I was gonna have to get
a PhD um did you rebel against that are
you you had a lot that every so often
yeah I became a carpenter for a while
chef Hansen pretty early on became
obsessed with this idea of figuring out
how the mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain works then
he got into psychology and then finally
he settled on more of a computer science
approach to modeling the brain and got
into artificial intelligence my feeling
is if you want to understand a really
complicated device like a brain you
should build one I mean you could look
at cars and you could think you could
understand cars when you try and build a
car you suddenly discover then there's
this stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work
yeah this job was starting to think
about these ideas he got inspired by
some AI researchers across the pond
specifically this guy Frank Rosenblatt
Rosenblatt in the late 1950s developed
what he called a perceptron and it was a
neural network a computing system that
would mimic the brain
the basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons these are little
computing units but they're actually
modeled on the way that the human brain
does its computation they take incoming
data like we do from our senses and they
actually learn so the neural net can
learn to make decisions over time
Rosenblatt's hope was that you could
feed a neural network a bunch of data
like pictures of men and women and it
would eventually learn how to tell them
apart just like humans do
there was just one problem it didn't
work very well
Rosenblatt his neural network was the
single layer of neurons and it was
limited in what it could do extremely
limited and a colleague of his wrote a
book in the late 60s that showed these
limitations and it kind of put the whole
area of research into a deep freeze for
a good ten years no one wanted to work
in this area they were sure it would
never work well almost no one
it was just obvious to me that it was
right way to go the brains are big
neural network and so it has to be that
stuff like this can work because it
works in our brains it's just never any
doubt about that now what do you think
it was inside of you that kept you on
him to pursue this when everyone else
was giving up just that you thought it
was the right direction to go everyone
else was wrong okay
[Laughter]
Hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural nets might work and he's
gonna pursue it no matter what for a
little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the u.s. he
kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the Defense Department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go I didn't want to take Defense
Department money I sort of didn't like
the idea that this stuff was gonna be
used for purposes that I didn't think
we're good he suddenly hears the Canada
might be interested in funding
artificial intelligence and that was
very attractive but I could go off to
this civilized town and just get on with
so I came to the University of Toronto
and then in the mid-80s we discovered
how to make more complicated neural nets
so they could solve those problems of
the simple ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layer neural network a deep neural
network
and this started to work in a lot of
ways using the neural networks a guy
named Dean Pomerleau built a
self-driving car in the late 80s and it
drove on public roads yawn Laocoon in
the 90s built a system that could
recognize handwritten digits and this
ended up being used commercially but
again they hit a ceiling and went quite
well enough because we didn't have
enough data we didn't have enough
compute power and people in AI in
computer science and society neural
networks was wishful thinking reasoning
so it was a big disappointment
through the dinies into the 2000s jeff
was one of only a handful of people on
the planet who were still pursuing this
technology he would show up at academic
conferences and be banished to the back
rooms he was treated as really like a
pariah was there like a time when you
thought this just wasn't gonna work and
and you didn't have some self-doubt I
mean I the many times that I thought I'm
not gonna make this work but Jeff was
consumed by this and couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn until about 2006
when the world catches up to Hinton's
ideas
[Music]
Computers and I look awesome and now
it's behaving like I thought it will
behave in the mid-80s
it's solving everything the arrival of
super fast chips and the massive amounts
of data produced on the internet gave
Hinton's algorithms a magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image then they could
recognize speech and translate from one
language to another by 2012 words like
neural Nets and machine learning we're
popping up on the front page of the New
York Times you have to go all these
years and then all of a sudden you know
in the span of a few months
yes takes off did it finally feel like
aha
you know the world has finally come to
my vision there's sort of a relief that
people finally came to their senses
for hinton this was clearly a redemptive
moment after decades of toil
and for Canada it meant something even
bigger
incident his students put the country on
the map as an AI superpower something
no-one and no computer could ever have
predicted thanks for watching and if you
want to see more hello world click on
the link to subscribe